welcome to this video playing Maradona
from the all on the island seller I
think he has some changed the flag at
some point okay let's see playing the
mark icon maybe though exchange now
that's really a bit dull let's let's
play the more more active continuation
sorry a bit bit later should definitely
wrap up this session after the game mmm
that's an uncommon moment to play this
he cannot go at five now and i will have
Bishop e2 basically kicking the night
bag he lost them a tempo in the process
my Diaz h4 h5 and down okay it takes
takes just take twice on yeah probably
yeah shop g4 that's just one of the
interesting news if he goes Bishop d3 a
bishop e6 check yeah or against this I
also have this check I just wonder if it
is really doing that much night before
is of course in idn I have 94
Jack Michaela I can I can give this
check it shouldn't be any any any bad
night before maybe just a three come on
let's let's invest in this figure was 95
I can just take it and this is really
the key counterplay okay my idea is
between F 3G 3G army yeah I must take it
I really have not a big don't have a big
choice but what's now Queen f3 g3 I
guess night oh it has 94 maybe I have
crazy fun okay that's very important
okay if i go here between no night h5 i
have Quincy for complicated
okay just cancel them I need to use all
my pieces yeah that position is really
not clear at all I mean at first I
thought I should be quite quite
significantly better but how do I get
get some progress going here night I try
the aphorism is an additional idea
maybe I should have moved the Queen just
to get out of this temple yeah neither
43 years now if now immediately or
instantly threatening
he won probably wasn't a great idea
I can go here actually and then take on
the form but he's attacking the bishops
bow wow what a bad game
you can take and just plain i def for i
think because 96 is such a big threat i
probably have to move the night at the
bishop away yeah after this game i will
definitely stop this session I mean he
just gave me a whole temple and in the
opening which is already not too great
for him and still I have problems
I'm not quite sure why he's not my wine
night f4 is not being played what is the
the big issue with this move why isn't
he playing it I mean 94-96 should be
okay he just does not play it don't
really know why this what is happening
after this more now this I didn't seem
fantastic okay
yeah f2 is just hanging
I don't know I completely lost any sort
of control in this position that's just
total mess maybe you can just take it on
f2 here Knight d4
yeah I don't know I completely lost any
sort of any sort of control iam not sure
what's going on probably just lost I can
take here take you seven but i wanna
saying it's got Roxy to even here
threatening made on g7 as well am I lost
year I don't know i mean it looks it
looks really totally strange look-see to
king d once they're made I don't see it
at the moment I to check he can give it
to check oopsie to put maybe I can go to
be one actually maybe I can take here
wow I'm in the game I don't I don't
believe it I'd ever even overlook that
this is hanging well this was this is
one of the worst games ever really it is
one of the worst games I'd remember wow
what a game
check check check check mmm normal check
i'm julie mated him my what what I came
check draw on word game dry area this
was I mean yeah let's see the comp is on
minus 15 hmm not too surprising yeah now
now from minus 15 it is it is 200 again
and here yeah yeah come on they're
simply if simply no words for all that
here rookie 3 is winning for white yeah
but I mean how on earth did I did it
come to that I mean around here this is
this should just be overwhelmingly good
for white the whole line is not great
for black and I just wanted one a
complete temple with this night h5
business that he played why am I not
better here
maybe this I mean from maybe Bishop g4
is really not good I mean yeah it looks
very attractive to put the bishop on his
six but yeah or maybe a three was the
mistake I don't really know I can't I
can't play that maybe that's better any
I thought Knight f6 oops and they're not
this one I thought Knight f6 maybe but
you have all the computer the computer
it points out night g5 with a big
advantage yeah this this this I move her
obviously didn't see and it's very
strong he cannot take it at all this is
a disaster with the age file opening up
hmm yeah yeah if I have h5 this this is
what my opponent moved me here widest
just just very much better also this one
this one coming like a son like is in
very bad shape I should really have some
advantage because he just lost the whole
tempo on a line as mentioned that it's
not great at all but down a three is
this is just just too slow and TM again
I think I mean this is problem this was
probably not great at all yeah I mean I
also didn't understand why why not why
not might age five it's just
yeah yeah I'm winning the house here
that's black and I'm just worse with
night age 58 was a totally bad game this
is what he played and again nine age
five yeah he did play Knight f4
strangely enough already thought that
this is just good for black boobs you
know with this check and this is also
quite nice for black of those two
bishops very strong yeah also a good
line for black yeah I'm totally busted
yeah what a messy game all right i
should really end the session thanks for
watching